- YouTube, as good of
a clip as I've ever had
about loving what you do on a daily basis,
this was a big one, D-Rock
and I are completely
convinced this is gonna
be one of the most viewed
videos we've ever had, so
let's see if we're right.
- Good to see ya.
I'm doin' super well.
- How're you doin?
Are you good?
- Real good.
- I've been just like all that crazy,
the last like two, three
months I was hospitalized,
I was sort of just depressed
and suicidal and stuff,
and it's getting stressful because now
the mind, the fears, the game of all this.
- What's it tellin' you?
- This process, patience, go through it,
but it's a lot of missteps in it.
- It means you're absorbing patience.
- It's there though, that's the thing,
and I'm aware.
- You're aware of it.
- I'm aware of it.
- Now you gotta connect to it.
You gotta ask why though.
My biggest thing is why are
you worried about other people?
'Cause that's where it's comin' from.
- My process of goin' in
and how the finish line
is gonna look to other people.
- 100%, like literally
that guy just repeated
we're fronting 50 times in a row
right before you.
- That's my favorite
song of all time, that is the one.
- Fronting is a mistake.
You're letting other
people's judgment matter.
How old are you?
- I'm 21.
- Dude, do you know how
shit on I got at 21?
I worked in my daddy's liquor store
makin' seven bucks an hour.
People shit on me.
- I'm shitting on myself though
'cause it's like a little
virus, we pass it in here--
- No, no you're shitting
on yourself because,
you're not shitting on yourself,
you're letting your homie, or your aunt,
or somebody else shit on
you, it's goin' in your head,
and now you think you're
shitting on yourself.
- Right.
- Bro, you're lettin' other people's,
this is very complicated,
but unbelievably simple.
You're worried about
what other people think.
- I get the support though from people,
I get the love.
- That's good.
- But it just gets conflicted so much.
- What do you want to happen?
- I just, I don't know man.
- You gotta figure out
what makes you happy
on your terms.
- I really don't know.
- That's okay though, that's,
I think you're dwelling
and putting more compounded
pressure on yourself
for something that every
21 year old is living.
You know how many 21 year olds know?
(clicks tongue)
- There should at least be a goal,
like something to look
forward to so you can have--
- How 'bout being happy?
- The sneakers.
- Fuck sneakers man, the fact--
- No, so you can have your
shoes on to run for the race
kind of thing--
- Got it, got it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's cool, that's
fine, but I'm tellin' you,
make it the process of
life, not some sort of goal.
Even the Jets thing's a front.
I wanna try to buy the Jets.
What it really means is I
love the process so much
that I wanna do somethin' so big, really,
so I can do the process.
Fuck the buying the Jets.
I want the fuckin' process of trying.
You gotta fall in love with
doing something everyday,
not what the fuck's it gonna get you,
or what the goal is, that
arbitrary shit up there
is fuckin' you up.
I'm being serious.
Just what do you like to do?
Do it and eat on it, and
if that's being an artist,
and you can only eat like a
fuckin' McDonald's everyday,
then you're good.
You gotta fall in love with the thing.
You gotta get to that place.
- And not judge it too hard
when it doesn't feel great.
- My god, you're judging it.
You're judging yourself,
you're fuckin' Judge Judy
on your life.
- 1000%.
- Get out of it, I don't
judge myself for shit,
you don't like it?
It didn't go well today?
Fuck you.
I say fuck you to all you
'cause I say fuck you to myself.
I don't judge myself.
You know why?
'Cause everybody else sucks too.
Everybody else sucks
too, they just might be
fuckin' thinkin' it better than you.
- They're frontin' on it.
I love you G.
- I love you back bro.
Please leave a real
comment of what struck you
in this video.
Hope you enjoyed it.